1984 le téléphérique de grenoble fête
ses 50 ans d'existence premier de ce
genre en site urbain il est devenu
depuis trente-quatre l'une des
attractions les plus marquantes de la
ville environ deux cent mille voyageurs
effectuent chaque année le trajet qui
les emmènent duc et stéphane j jusqu'à
la bastille à certaines périodes de vous
avez des italiens qui correspondent à
certaines fêtes
et puis maintenant vous avez beaucoup
d'anglais américains hollandais qui
commencent à arriver allemand que c'est
une grosse période touristique et ce
n'est pas le spécialement la clientèle
régionale mais au contraire la clientèle
de tourisme car il veut ardeurs france
et qui traverse et s'arrête une journée
ou plus dans notre région pour découvrir
l'ensemble de la ville il vous en
coûtera 25 francs aller-retour
s'il vous reste un peu de temps
n'hésitez pas à visiter le musée
dauphinois c'est un autre atout de
grenoble dernier point la rentabilité
apparemment tout marche bien nous sommes
depuis 1984 une régie autonome un
établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial dans le but
était de rentabiliser l'entreprise en
tout état de cause l'équilibré et je
peux vous dire que c'est chose faite
maintenant